♪♪
[ Old-fashioned music playing ]
-Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Right now, I'm joined
by a lovely lady,
an actress by the name
of Ms. Elizabeth Olsen.
[ Applause ]
-Evening, Jim.
-How are you doing?
Are you comfortable?
I see they got you a water.
-Water? Well, that's an odd way
to pronounce rum punch.
[ Audience laughs ]
-So you star in
a new picture called
"The Boxcar Gals and
the Fellas from Tulum."
Tell me, was it hard?
-Oh, Jim, it was a hoot.
-No, I mean
remembering the title.
[ Audience laughs ]
-Ohh.
-Say, don't blame me. I'm
just a fella with a desk job.
-[ Spits ]
-Well, now, that's a punch line.
-Emphasis on the "punch."
[ Crackling ]
-[ Distorted ] Jimmy.
Who's doing this to you, Jimmy?
-Gee, did you hear that?
-I--I -- I don't -- no.
No, I don't hear a thing.
[ Feedback crackles ]
♪♪
Good evening, I'm Jimmy Fallon
broadcasting live in color
from Rock Center.
Tonight, my guest is
a far-out young artist.
Please welcome Elizabeth Olsen.
[ Applause ]
-Excited to be here.
-I'm glad you swung by.
And I'm glad you brought
your own cigarette.
-Oh, sure, yeah.
This is a....
cigarette.
[ Audience laughs ]
-Now, you're giving us the
lowdown on your new film,
titled "Stop Dipping Your Toes
In My Kool-Aid:
Tales from the Mind Palace."
-We're really sticking it
to the man with this one.
-Well, as long as you're not
sticking this man
into a theater seat --
[ Audience laughs ]
-Hey --
Jimmy, why aren't we together?
[ Audience oohs ]
-Well, I'm flattered,
but I'm already hitched.
[ Audience awws ]
-No, no, no, no.
I mean...
why aren't we in the same room?
Why are we in these --
these...boxes?
[ Hum growing ]
Jimmy...
we've got to get out of here.
-No.
[ Feedback crackles ]
♪♪
We back?
Cool.
We're here with
a crazy-talented actress,
You know her, you love her.
Lizzie Olsen, guys!
[ Applause ]
Uh, Liz?
Need a chill pill?
-[ Scoffs ] As if.
[ Audience laughs ]
I just needed a sec to...
Wait.
Who's laughing?
-Uh, Tipper Gore?
Who do you think?
[ Audience laughs ]
-No, seriously, who's laughing?
Jimmy, you don't
have an audience.
Are you doing all of this?
Is this because you want things
to be back to normal, right?
Like before the pandemic?
No. No, don't --
[ Feedback crackles ]
♪♪
-Welcome back, guys!
I'm here with Elizabeth Olsen.
Uh...
You good, bud?
-Jimmy, you have to stop.
I know the present is scary and
we all want COVID to be over,
but you can't just run
from your problems.
-You know that's --
that's a great point.
Anyway, it's time to
Lick It for 10!
-Jimmy, snap out of it, okay?
This isn't reality.
I know you're trying to cope.
I know that.
But you can't keep
controlling all of this.
-I--I'm not
controlling all of --
-Jimmy.
[ Sad music playing ]
Look at me.
It's okay.
You can let go.
Jimmy.
Let...go.
[ Feedback crackles ]
♪♪
-Hey, guys! Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm here via Zoom with the one
and only Elizabeth Olsen.
-Hi, Jimmy.
Are you ready to do this?
-I think I am.
Now, everyone's
going crazy for this.
You've got to tell me about
your new show "WandaVision."
[ Feedback crackles ]
-Wait, it's -- it's still --
But if it wasn't you,
then who was it?
-Ohh, poor Elizabeth.
-Wait, Kathryn Hahn.
What are you doing here?
-What can I say?
TV just isn't
what it used to be.
[ Audience laughs ]
-♪ Who's been messing up
everything? ♪
-♪ It's been Kathryn Hahn
all along ♪
♪♪